apple leaks have been getting absolutely
insane over the past couple of months
and they've been getting quite a bit
weird in terms of the mac lineup that we
should be expecting this year and then
going on into next year because they're
just such different takes out there but
mark german just came out with a
bombshell report claiming that apple is
currently testing at least nine
new m2 based macs and this completely
changes the game he even says that the
new machines are already appearing in
third-party app analytics which is just
further proof for this happening and as
you know over the past few days we've
been putting out some leaked videos like
this one saying that the macbook air
2022 redesign is in deep trouble and
that was mainly based on the chance of
the redesigned macbook air getting the
old
m1 chip which i know that sounds weird
but i'm going to explain in just a
minute and then going on to a video we
put out yesterday there was a chance
that the new mac mini would come with
the m1 pro chip with a lot of evidence
for that but potentially even the m2 now
those leaks especially the macbook air
one are coming from ming chi kuo yes
he's a pretty reliable analyst and he's
been around for a very long time and the
weird thing is when last month he said
that the macbook air could come with a
new design but with the same m1 chip
which at first that made absolutely no
sense to me but he also made the leak of
where the new iphone 14 regular models
could come with the same a15 chip yes
reusing the old silicon and the reason
for that would be differences in the
pricing and of course with all the
supply chain stuff going on so if
they're willing to do this for the
iphone maybe they're also willing to
give the old macbook air the m1 chip
especially since it's a consumer based
product where people don't really care
what chip it has because the m1 is
honestly fast enough and the biggest
reason i thought this could actually
happen was because of the crazy shang
high lockdowns and just this morning
ming choco came out and he said that
apple is doing its best to negotiate
with the chinese government with the
goal of reopening suppliers production
lines that were shut down due to the
lockdown starting next week at the
earliest and he said he's not sure if
apple can succeed but it might explain
why apple supply chain has not seen any
significant order cuts due to the
lockdown so maybe apple was able to
succeed and get that open and that is a
game changer and it's part of the reason
why apple might be going forward with
the m2 chip for the max this year and of
course next year and now getting into
mark german's report on the m2 chips he
says that there are going to be at least
four different m2 base chips and there's
evidence of them inside logs within
third-party apps which is very very
important to us seeing them hopefully
soon so with that said he said these are
the new machines that we should be
expecting first of all we have a macbook
air with the m2 chip codenamed j413
and that's gonna have eight cpu cores
likely a four performance core for
efficiency core layout and then 10 cores
for the graphics that's two extra cores
compared to the current macbook air so
that's already a good piece of evidence
that this year's macbook air is gonna
have the m2 instead of the m1 which is
very reassuring
he goes on to say that the mac mini
should come with the m2 chip codenamed
j473 and that's basically going to have
the same specs as the macbook air and he
also said that there's an m2 pro
variation codenamed j474
in testing and that is likely going to
come out next year then he goes on to
say that there's going to be an entry
level macbook pro with an m2 chip
codenamed
j493 and that's also going to have the
same specs as the macbook air now to me
that seems really weird because with the
m1 macbook lineup a lot of people just
chose to buy the macbook air because it
wasn't worth spending 300 more for the
macbook pro because there weren't enough
advantages so i think this i don't know
might be a mistake by apple unless
something changes to have the same ship
with the same specs within two different
machines at two different price points
but moving on he goes on to say that the
14 inch macbook pro
will get the m2 pro and m2 max chips
codenamed
j414 and the interesting thing there is
that it's supposed to have a 12 core cpu
so i think it's gonna get two extra
efficiency cores and a 38 core gpu
that's the highest level you can get
which is really weird because the
previous one was 32 so going up to 38 is
a little bit weird i think it makes
sense to have 40 but maybe they might
just disable two of those gpu cores just
for better yields and then of course we
have the 16 inch macbook pro with
exactly the same options as a 14 inch
which makes sense because that's exactly
what we have now that's code named
j416 and then finally here's the weird
one we have the mac pro codenamed j180
and this machine will include a
successor to the m1 ultra chip used in
the mac studio so that means it's going
to be the m2 ultra now going back to
mark's report one thing he mentioned is
that apple was also testing a mac mini
with an m1 pro chip yes just like in the
video i just made yesterday the m1 pro
chip the same processor that's in the 14
and 16 inch macbook pros that one being
codenamed j374
however he is saying that maybe the mac
studio made that machine redundant and
maybe it caused apple just to cancel it
and wait for the m2 versions yes the two
that he mentions right here j473 and
j474
with the m2 chip and the m2 pro now
interestingly this actually echoes a
report from nine to five mac an
exclusive report where they were able to
find the apple is in fact working on the
m2 and the m2 pro and according to them
apple did have plans to introduce higher
end versions of the mac mini with the m1
pro and ml max chips but they were
probably scrapped for the mac studio so
that perfectly matches up to what mark
german said
and with that said we should be
hopefully getting the m2 mac mini this
year and that's exactly what mark german
said in his report saying that a new
macbook air load macbook pro and a new
mac mini are scheduled to debut as early
as this year with at least two of those
macs planned for launch around the
middle of the year so he is saying that
we should be getting the m2 chip around
the middle of the year which kind of
matches up to wwdc so that would be very
interesting because there are other
sources like bob on twitter who
admittedly does not have a good track
record but some of the stuff he said
made sense before but he believes it's
not coming at wwdc in terms of the m2
chips so i'm not sure what's going on
here but mark german definitely has
better credibility compared to this bomb
now the last thing i want to mention is
that 9-5 mac did have another exclusive
report that a new macbook air and
13-inch macbook pro are coming later
this year with the m2 chip so that
basically means that ming chukwu would
be wrong in his prediction that the
macbook air would come with the m1 ship
and also when he was saying that the mac
mini would get delayed until 2023 so i
think this is actually wrong because i
do expect a mac mini this year probably
with the m2 chip at this point even
though there is a chance that we could
get it with the m1 pro but going back to
mark german's report in his tweet i
think this does make sense especially if
apple is able to figure out all of the
supply chain issues and the lockdown
issues in shanghai
if that is true then i think we could
very well likely be seeing m2 chips
especially since there's proof of apple
testing them and working on them already
so with that said hopefully you guys
enjoyed this video and let me know your
thoughts on all these different leaks
down in the comments section below
hopefully you enjoyed it definitely
click the circle above to subscribe for
more videos like this one check out one
of those two right over there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video